um as you may know the american
right-wing has made a big bet
on cultural issues in the united states
for the last many years increasingly so
as i talked about in a segment before
our recent break
and part of this has been noticeable in
the total lack of policy discussion by
the republican party it's it's basically
a playbook of
call the left socialists and communists
oppose everything democrats want to do
and try to win on that platform and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't work quite so well the other
part of course
is waging war on issues like
cancel culture which we've talked about
now must be a dozen times
and as a quick cliff note remember that
donald trump campaigned
on being against cancer culture his
cronies
fellow republicans have endlessly ranted
about being against
suppression of speech against regulation
of businesses
against all of it we knew it was always
a ruse
we knew it was always a way to hype
people up
in order to get them activated get
donations out of them
frame the left as evil authoritarian
suppressors of speech
and it's come full circle now donald
trump and republicans
after months of denouncing supposed
cancel culture on the left
are demanding boycotts of countless
organizations and companies because
they don't like the speech being
expressed
by those companies it's hard to pinpoint
exactly where this fiasco started
but a big part of it was voter
suppression bills
in a number of states including notably
georgia
georgia passed a bill that would
significantly restrict voting and make
it harder to vote
one organization that spoke out that's
speech
about the bill was major league baseball
major league baseball
was scheduled to have their all-star
game in georgia and i believe they're
a draft as well they've pulled it
because of the georgia bill this is not
trivial
the tourism industry experts believe
that pulling the all-star game
will cost georgia about 100
million dollars now there is a real
argument that there's a good faith
argument to be had
about whether major league baseball and
others who are now saying boycott
georgia
are actually hurting the people who pass
the bill
versus hurting people who just work at
all sorts of businesses that would
benefit
from having the all-star game there
that's a fair debate that i
totally respect that debate but donald
trump has come out and said
boycott everyone who is participating in
the boycotts
or even speaking out against the georgia
bill and other bills
trump delivering his delusional easter
message
which we are going to look at saying for
years
the radical left democrats have played
dirty
by boycotting products when anything
from that company
is done or stated in any way that
offends them now they are
going big time with woke cancel culture
and our sacred elections it is finally
time for republicans and conservatives
to fight back
we have more people than they do by far
look at this boycott major league
baseball
coca-cola delta airlines
jpmorgan chase viacom cbs citigroup
cisco ups and merck don't go back to
their products until they relent
we can play the game better than them
trump saying we can
out cancel the cancel culture people
they didn't even get approval of state
legislatures which is mandated under the
u.s constitution
and then he throws in they rigged and
stole our 2020 presidential election
which we won by a landslide and then on
top of that
boycott and scare companies into
submission never submit
never give up says trump the radical
left will destroy
our country if we let them we will not
become a socialist nation i don't know
what that has to do with anything
and then trump saying hap happy easter
this is the cancel culture trump claims
to be against
this is donald trump a former president
no less saying cancel these companies
because they have the wrong opinion by
which he means an opinion trump doesn't
like
now as a total side note this is just
from my experience over the vacation
week
trump saying boycott delta i hope his
followers do i just flew last week fully
vaccinated of course with a mask
with a test negative test doctors were
shocked by how well i did on my test
the number of right wingers on my
flights who just insisted on taking
their masks off at every opportunity
continually oops i forgot to put my mask
back on after having one sip
of my water i believe the skies would be
much
safer if trumpists boycotted flying all
together for the time being
have at it okay that rant aside
one of the things i really like about
the joe biden presidency so far
is that joe biden isn't erratically and
hyperbolically weighing in
on all of these issues some people are
saying boycott others are saying don't
okay joe biden said he would support
moving the all-star game out of georgia
over the law
and that's it he's busy governing he's
busy getting four million
shots multiple days in a row into the
arms of people which we will talk about
tomorrow
let others decide what to do and who to
boycott but the irony of trump
supposedly against cancel culture making
himself the canceler in chief is really
stunning and this is the case with
everything
we we've exposed this for a decade on
the show they're against deficit
increases until their guy is in office
and wants to go to war or give tax cuts
for the rich
they're against cancelling things unless
it's them doing the canceling
and on and on i won't go through a dozen
examples because we've done it so many
times before
their stated principles mean nothing
when circumstances change and we will
have
more coverage of this on our instagram
page find us
at davidpakmanshow on instagram and
find pictures from our spring break
you will see how safely i was living
spring break
on my instagram at david.pacman
by the way uh about a hundred people
unfollowed me on instagram when i posted
a picture of myself at a beach pointing
out that i was fully
vaccinated and a bunch of people saying
why aren't you wearing a mask like i'm
by myself on a beach why
why would i be wearing a mask but you
know what that's their right
i'm not nobody's canceling anybody it's
a beautiful thing anyway david.pakman on
instagram quick break back after this
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them
they're the only vpn with an always-on
third-party audit
verifying that your internet activity is
not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off
a one year plan which is less than six
bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman